this is Meg from Fandango movie clips
with 50 facts about Fifty Shades of Grey
that's a lot of freaking facts on dive
right in
[Music]
I'll start off nice and easy it's based
on the book the same name written by Al
James James his real name is Erica
Mitchell it's the first book in a series
of three fifty shades darker file by
fifty shades free James listen to sexy
by the Black Eyed Peas while writing
sexy the series is based on Twilight fan
fiction fan fiction has never come to
the big screen till now thanks to
Universal who purchased the film rights
for five million bucks the book sold
more copies than The DaVinci Code and
Harry Potter and the Deathly Hallows
speaking of Potter author JK Rowling
refuses to read it what a muggle
but Oprah on the other hand is a big fan
many US libraries have banned the book
when it hit bookshelves in Pennsylvania
there's a huge increase in the sale of
rope duct tape and cable ties
I always knew those almond for kinky
keep it at kinky Christian Grey's all
about BDSM bondage and discipline
domination and Submission sadism and
masochism poured a mouthful he's not
alone it's estimated that 15 to 20
percent of Americans have enjoyed the
pain of BDSM also the u.s. is allegedly
home to over 3,000 sex clubs time to
turn up the heat Suns an anarchy star
Charlie Hunnam was originally cast as
Christian Grey sorry I was picturing
jacks naked it lets off of me lucky for
kami Jordan hadn't dropped out crowning
him the news break
get into character he visited a private
sex dungeon it must have been really
hard for him Jamie's from Belfast
Ireland where he's a rugby player
move over Bieber he was a real Calvin
Klein model also the face of CEO to top
it off he was in a band don't get too
excited ladies he's married his wife's
Amelia Warner and the two welcome to
daughter last November hard goddess
Anastasia Steele is played by Dakota
Johnson
her parents are actors Melanie Griffith
and Don Johnson she does not want her
fair see in the film Donald Blamey girl
her grandmother is actors Tippi Hedren
stars the birds the last screen test the
lucky actress who should have been Dean
and Jeannie acted out the first and last
chapters of the book Dakota their
co-stars only had five
our lines impressive she's all tied up
in the weekends birthday music video
hashtag not-safe-for-work also in the
soundtrack is Ellie Goulding's hit song
love me like you do even Queen Bey got
in on the action recording an all new
frontier version of crazy in love that's
featured in the first trailer behind
every great bondage scene is a great
director me Sam taylor-johnson director
of nowhere boy which starter husband
Aaron taylor-johnson he makes a cameo in
the film they have two children and yes
she's a cougar he's 23 years her junior
ain't that the road that Angelina Jolie
passed at the opportunity to direct yes
she wasn't in the mood to do her own
biopic now for the climax Jamie will not
appear fully nude unfair said women
everywhere also not included the tampon
scene no objections there Kelly Marcel
screenwriter of saving mr. banks wrote
the script of a big action writer mark
bomback of dawn of the Planet of the
Apes and the Wolverine Sun shineth the
film is rated R for unusual behavior and
broke fandango records and the fastest
selling r-rated film don't fret pervs an
nc-17 blu-ray is rumored it has a
runtime of an hour and 50 minutes so be
sure to pee beforehand bonus fact if it
wasn't obvious by now they'll be back so
much Zac mind-blowing crazy bag dirty
sex gross sex scary sex whatever sex I'm
Meg from Fandango because thanks for
watching I hope it was as good for you
as it was for me don't forget to see 50
shades of grey in theaters February 13
[Music]